so we have an exciting new update
regarding the love and thunder trailer
so as we know the love and thunder
trailer has been the longest wait for
any marvel film but it looks like we may
not have to wait for too much longer so
according to a brazilian website they're
saying that the trailer for this film
will release next monday on april 18th
along with a poster for the film now
apparently they have a pretty good
reputation for sources such as this
however you know me and if it doesn't
come from something official always take
it with a grain of salt because you
never know but in saying that we have
gotten word from an official source that
the dubbing for the love and thunder
trailer has been completed with the
caption for love and thunder trailer
done can't wait for you guys to see it
now the dubbing is usually the last
thing which they do for a trailer so the
trailer at this point is most likely
completed which is very very exciting
and most likely they're just waiting to
release it at the right time which
according to the rumor which we covered
before is april 18 which is just one
week away so this is true we only have
one week to go into this trailer and
surely the trailer has to be close
because there's so many leaks going
around for upcoming toys and merchandise
for this film which we've been given our
first look at gore here played by
christian bale and i know there was some
controversy around the design of this
character because it's not comic
accurate and he doesn't really look
alien but guys let's just wait until we
see the trailer or the film at least i
think christian bale is going to kill it
as going is going to give a really great
performance but you guys do you think
we'll get the trailer next week we've
been waiting a really long time to get a
look at this film so it's about time
without the way that's pretty much
everything about this video so if you
did enjoy please like and subscribe and
turn notifications on to show your
support thanks for watching